[Music]
see the near their products a little
veneer aficionado my killer panel is the
faucet the more the electrons
you know lon hello class
the fair loves fatality
[Music]
side
hopefully someone will own my business
my business and power
I'm not I guess I'm saying problem below
as an individual effect Lanie but there
were no more dozen young modern Yaniv
all along my something - an overly
qualified
[Music]
I know the runway some papa
so Eric could get their money to move
again so do this
[Music]
I thought lately but it make an igniter
they've got a lot of homework something
lives you know what happened
Ohama taking you look near and then
execute funny
they even booked another bottle
[Music]
yeah
we got the father say Denis
no no W sees how a third man agrarian it
was a missing value of MU
[Music]
you know more happiness
they'll surely a good intention down
bahala Teddy's agree with you more on
eHarmony and you know texting but my way
egotistical using them both naked
[Music]
you